It's really been an interesting four years
from Sean Hannity, he went from already prominent
right wing propagandist on Fox News, really
to a presidential insider, I mean, a friend
of Donald Trump's who not so much recently,
but certainly earlier on in his administration,
Hannity and Trump often speaking on the phone
at night.
Hannity was sometimes the last person Trump
would speak to before, I guess, going to bed.
If that's something Donald Trump does, I don't
know.
He doesn't really seem to do anything the
way most of us do.
But in any case, Sean Hannity had really become
an insider, sometimes traveling on Trump's
helicopter or on Air Force One.
He would do these sycophantic softball interviews
of Trump.
He would do sycophantic interviews of Kayleigh
McEnany and many others.
Well, Sean Hannity's ratings have absolutely
collapsed since the election.
And Eric Boehlert has some great reporting
on this.
Fox has actually been touting the latest ratings
numbers as a big win for Sean Hannity.
And a lot of publications fell for it.
And they put together headlines that make
it seem like everything is going great for
Hannity.
Fox, for example, running an article on December
16th called Sean Hannity.
Tucker Carlson set records as Fox News makes
history in 20/20 cable news ratings.
But the truth is there has been a massive
decline.
Hannity's show falling into last place for
the nine p.m. time slot among what's called
the key demographic, the 25 to 54 demographic.
Hannity stuck in that last place for two months
now.
Now, it is true that Hannity still has a ton
of viewers in the aggregate, but the declines
have been significant.
And part of the reason is people are abandoning
Fox for further loony right wing content on
Newsmax and on.
And I've been teasing that later this week,
we're going to look in detail at an incredible
a focus group done by Frank Luntz with Trump
hosts.
And many of them say Fox is too left.
We're now with Newsmax.
And and so part of Hannity's decline is that
and they're sort of good and bad.
They're it's good that fewer people are watching
Hannity, but it's bad that lots of them are
watching something even crazier.
Instead, others have abandoned Hannity and
they started to in December when it became
clear that all of Hannity's commentary about
how Trump is just about to overturn the results
any day now.
This is the path, Mr. Mayor.
Rudy, tell us, what's the once it became clear
that wasn't going to happen?
There were some, I guess you would call them
deflated.
Trump is who also abandoned.
And it's also relevant to think about the
untold damage that Hannity did throughout
Trump's presidency.
And one of the reasons Trump didn't face the
same fate as Richard Nixon is there's a far
more radical Republican Party today.
But another reason that Trump didn't face
Richard Nixon's fate is the right wing media
apparatus that's so robust and powerful in
the 21st century that didn't exist in the
1970s during Richard Nixon's Watergate scandal.
So this is funny because I mean, listen, it's
funny because it's funny, but it's also interesting
because there are real questions about what
right wing media will look like during the
next, for example, two years, the first two
years of Joe Biden's presidency.
And what will be the lead up to the 2022 midterm
elections?
Something else that's important, the size
of the pie for radical right wing propaganda
is not getting any bigger right now.
So at the beginning of Trump's candidacy and
presidency, Trump brought in a lot of people
who were never into politics.
That grew the pie for right wing media, people
who never paid attention to politics, started
to Fox was after being against Trump early
in the Republican primary of 2016, eventually
supported Trump and all of this new audience,
people who never watched the news before were
watching Fox and Newsmax was able to get a
little bit of it away and was able to get
a little bit of it.
But now, as of twenty twenty, the demand for
radical right disinformation, propaganda,
it's not growing in the aggregate, which means
that Fox News has to sort of split its audience
with 018 and with Newsmax.
So right now, when Newsmax grows, some portion
of that growth is coming at the expense of
Fox News.
When Ogen grows, some portion of that growth
is coming at the expense of Fox News.
And it's more Zero-Sum than it's been in a
very long time.
It's not completely zero sum, but that's also
a factor.
There will no doubt be an impact to Fox News
from the reality that Newsmax and on have
bigger platform.
Forms than ever, who does Fox News need to
appeal to now, they already have the oldest
audience and those folks will mostly stay
with Fox News rather than going to Austin
and Newsmax.
The people that they need to appeal to are
the 25 to 54 key demographic who if you're
25 to 54 and you're watching FOX and you're
not pleased with them because they're not
right wing enough and you bailed to Fox to
honor Newsmax, how does Fox News when you
back?
I don't know the answer to that.
I don't have an answer.
And quite frankly, I don't care.
It's for Fox News to figure out, but it will
be interesting to follow.
Now, one other note about the size of the
pie.
Contrast this with independent left wing online
media.
Independent left wing online media has been
growing for two reasons over the last several
years.
Yes, part of it is being an opposition to
Trump.
The other part of it is that the pie is growing.
And what I mean by that is there are more
and more people who look for political content
on YouTube.
So when I get a new viewer, I'm not likely
to be taking it from Twitter or from Sam Ceder
or others.
It's more likely that someone is now getting
their analysis on YouTube instead of from
legacy corporate media.
That's a very different dynamic and I expect
that that's going to continue.